-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Amy Adams.
Before we move on, I have read
that you pick up hobbies
and maybe drop them
fairly quickly?
This was a time that
a lot of people were
at least trying new things
Did you --
Was there anything that stuck?
-No, but I did pick up
a lot of hobbies.
They just didn't stick.
I'm a big fan of
string instruments, apparently
I tried the ukulele,
the mandolin.
My husband got me this beautiful
cello for Christmas
a couple years ago.
Can't play the cello.
Still haven't tried to
play the cello.
I did try the ukulele.
I tried to learn "Party Favor"
by Billie Eilish.
-Uh-huh?
-And my daughter was like,
"Yeah, you can't --
You're not allowed to sing
Billie Eilish."
-I will say, the order seems t
be ukulele first,
not cello first.
That seems like an
incredibly ambitious present
to buy somebody.
-Well, I love the
sound of the cello,
and I think, you know,
he was being kind in
supporting my love of string
instruments that I can't play.
-Yeah, that definitely sound
like something you return
and you're like, "Do you have,
like, CDs were people
play cello
that I could just put on?"
-The funny thing is,
I still believe
I'm going to learn
all of this, Seth.
I still really believe tha
I'm going to be
proficient at
string instruments.
I don't know why.
-I like that.
I think we need more sort of
self-belief like that,
so I'm going to jump
on board, as well.
And let's set a time.
-Okay.
Let's say three years from now
you'll come on the show
and do cello for us.
-Okay. I can play like seven
chords on the guitar right now
so, hopefully,
maybe I'll just learn
those seven notes on the cello
We can come up
with a song or something.
-That sounds like a plan.
Hey, so, "Hillbilly Elegy"
is this book by J.D. Vance
and it's sort of his
personal history.
And he was involved in
the making of this film,
as was his mother.
Does it have --
I imagine it must have
an extra sense of responsibility
when you play a real perso
who's also nearby.
-Yeah, absolutely.
She came to set
a couple of times,
luckily through some of th
scenes that weren't as heavy
That would have been
really hard to film.
I do -- I have a really
huge sense of responsibility
in playing somebody
that's out there
and I know she's going to
be watching this.
But she was
incredibly courageous
and she's doing really well,
so that helps.
But it's intimidating.
I mean, like --
Yeah, everything about it.
Like, coming up with
the look, the --
She was going through a really
hard time, too, in the film,
so, again, I'm just really
grateful for her participation
-And you got to co-star
with Glenn Close.
And there's obviously a lot of
hair and makeup and wardrobe
in this film that makes you both
look very different
from how we're used to
seeing you.
But at the end of the film
it shows, I mean,
the wardrobe department,
the makeup department,
the hair department
did an incredible job.
You guys really hit the target
-Thank you.
Glenn -- when you see
the picture of Glenn and Mawmaw,
it is uncanny.
They look so similar, and
their mannerisms and everything.
She just nailed it.
She's amazing.
I loved working with her
and getting to know her.
She's a wonderful woman.
-I have not -- It was --
I moved from a few years ago
and it was heartbreaking,
because I used to live
in the same apartment building
in New York as Glenn Close
And seeing Glenn on the elevator
was just
the jackpot of jackpots.
Did you know her
particularly well
before you started
doing the film?
-I didn't know her very well
We're really lucky
because we got to stay
in this bed-and-breakfast
when we were shooting in
Clayton, Georgia.
I have the mug from it here,
which I've been drinking
water from.
It's, like, my favorite mug.
-That's a beautiful mug.
-Thank you.
Yeah, I think so, too.
It's from the
Beechwood bed-and-breakfast.
It's a -- And then there's
like, a wine --
They have wine there, too.
So we would sit with the win
and have coffee and, you know...
-Very natural.
You can tell, by the way
you're drinking from it,
that it's not your first sip
of anything from it.
-This is why I was never good at
commercials, Seth.
It's like, there's things
we're just not good at.
I'm bad with props.
-Yeah. It's true.
I think, especially in
a commercial --
In my early days, I had
a few commercial auditions
and when they put
a prop in the mix --
I mean, I'm not
a good actor to begin with
but it really, like,
cut my talent in half.
-Oh, I'm bad with props.
Every time they're like, "Okay
so, you're going to walk i
and you're gonna drop off your
purse and you're gonna dump it,"
I'm like, "Ooh!
Okay. How much time
do we have today?"
-Do you like --
Because I think some actor
really like to eat in scenes
because I think that takes the
out of their head.
Are you a good eating actor?
-Horrible.
-Really?
-I don't know if I
just have a dry mouth,
but I just always end up
with, like --
I can't get the,
like, food ratio,
and it always ends up gettin
in the way of the dialogue
And I always --
I'm just really bad at it.
I've seen people
who are really good eaters
I've worked with a couple.
-Yeah, I feel like Brad Pitt
could do, like, a "TED Talk" o
how to eat and act
at the same time --
or, like, one of those, like
"American Masters" series,
and I think anybody --
I would watch that.
-Yeah, you know how
they teach, like, stagecraft
where you learn how to
fight onstage or --
-Yeah.
-Yeah, that would be
a really important one,
I think, that I --
-Yeah, because, like,
when Brad Pitt's eating, like,
a sandwich in a scene,
you're just never worried
that he's going to
spit lettuce on anybody.
He just -- He seems very i
control of it.
-If I'm eating,
you're just sure.
You're like, "I'm not sure
where this ends up,
but it's not good."
-I will say,
I've seen films with you
where you start to eat,
I just turn it off.
Films I'm enjoying.
-I'm trying to think if
there's films.
"Julie & Julia," she eats a lot.
The Christmas scene -- I was
a master eater in that, so..
-That's a lot of pressure.
I mean, once again, like,
this proves
that you can play
a stringed instrument,
if you could get through
a whole film
where you had to eat that much
-If I could just
put my mind to it, yeah.
-It is always so lovely
to see you.
I wish you and your family
a very happy Thanksgiving,
and thanks, as always,
for making time for us, Amy.
-Thanks. You as well. Be well.